while republicans move forward on
another round of stimulus to get direct
payments into the hands of working
families nancy pelosi chuck schumer
uh guess what they don't really care
they're just once again resorting to
petty politics
wanting to stuff the package just like
they did the last time with a blue state
wish list
it will explain more house minority
leader kevin mccarthy
first of all they want three trillion
dollars
secondly they want people to make more
money
staying unemployed than being employed
is that correct
oh and by the way democrats want to
protect china from liability
well what they first want to do is no
longer 3 trillion they're now asking for
4 trillion
and remember in their 3 trillion dollar
bill it mentioned
cannabis more than it ever mentioned
research or jobs
this is what they have they just have a
wish list not a way forward
even today when you have unemployment
insurance the extra amount of money that
the federal government
puts in to extend it the republicans
said let's extend it a week while we
negotiate
you know who said no chuck schumer but
watch what they'll say out on television
the president was willing to continue to
go forward to protect those who are
unemployed right now build so we can get
people working again
and solve this problem every single time
we've worked on covet legislation
you know who's held it up nancy pelosi
remember at her at refrigerator when
small businesses needed the money
for their employees she said no or when
the very first cares act went forward
she said no and held it for another week
how many more people were unemployed
because of nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer's actions
it's unbelievable what else is hidden in
here
lindsey graham said today on my radio
show
that in fact they actually except for
one democrat
they want to prevent americans
that want to hold china responsible for
what they did to the world
from doing so why are they protecting
china
that is the biggest question i do not
know what the communist
party of china has on the democrats but
it is very powerful
it is so powerful when the chinese are
now hacking
to find our vaccines i put a bill on the
floor to sanction any hackers
they voted against it we now have a
report in a paper today
that the fbi says china is trying to
influence our election
and we know who they want to win and
also influence
members of congress they denied that in
foreign affairs vote just the other day
we even had the armed service chairman
say it wasn't china's fault it's not
their responsibility
to warn america about the virus trying
to blame the president
and adam schiff a real favorite of all
of ours you know what he said when we
closed down the houston consulate
the people said was the hub of espionage
he said it was all politics and he
blamed
america why won't nancy pelosi bring
those bills to the floor
that hold them accountable why because
they want to defend
china and blame america well there's an
election
in 96 days i'm hoping
and praying that if you're going to vote
for the president
maybe it's time to put nancy pelosi
in the minority and keep the senate
republican that would be helpful
that's the best thing you can do all
right so what you got to do is
which party's best to keep america safe
go to takethehouse.com if you want to
get rid of nancy pelosi
kevin mccarthy thank you for being with
us